welcome to this video w bri bri ok let's
see area catalan or something yeah we
get a catalan or maybe a ready depends
on his plate okay it's taking the pawn
let's see hmmm 2293 those kind of moves
are possible okay i'm going to make sure
to get the pots on keeping an eye on the
b5 square so b5 is not so easily
possible
hmm taking quite a while now I'm not
sure about that 93 okay very often you
can just play d 3 for compensation I
don't want to play Knight 93 immediately
to give him the opportunity to take in
one go I rather have them play Bishop
somewhere e 70 or not and then night a
three then takes this kind of thing I ok
night to before now as I DM
interesting let's see 95 night before
Quincy three very tough concrete
position early on well here's neglected
development and taken the pawn and yeah
well if he just gives me the pawn bag
with a move like this should be seven or
so why does Justin very nice shape so it
yes to do something very concrete
otherwise this whole opening set up is a
pretty substantial failure and this is
one night before is some probably the
move that should be played interesting
movie also maybe Bishop d7 yeah but
maybe I can you just take c4 okay so he
actually allows allows that yeah it's
not the end of the world would like but
definitely not what he wanted in the
first place so mayor this is in last
night's it too so let's start with this
one hmm
yeah let's eat or it's not not really
really great just attacking the rook I
move it okay that's it yeah so the
bishop 1c8 this is blacks issue so maybe
a move like be success an interesting
idea ok maybe be five okay I want to get
this in any way so we should a six now
then I can take and that was the idea
it's take now now Bishop f4 that looks
quite good the idea is that Bishop g6 I
can take take a fire that looks really
ugly for black and on any rope moves I
go d5 intending d6 that's a dynamic way
to play it activates all whites pieces
and I'm actually much much quicker than
this guy which does not really does
really impress because I'm never quick
out here just this time okay so I just
push the deep on that cannot be bad
really oh really you lousy d7 okay
that I have a hard time to believe that
this should shoot her word we should be
success the the principal threat now
don't think this is this is possible
be hard for him to to stop the porn I
really don't see how there should be six
is just wrong yeah this is difficult if
he lost tons of time with with the
knives and so on if you then just return
the pawn it cannot be that great I mean
of course this is not the dream scenario
public doesn't need to lose that quickly
but it was a was a problematic
problematic situation so Bush empty six
right it is a complete Rakim it's not
loading and exchange times Jeff this is
so something way he has to be precise I
was thinking actually be six could be an
idea this cannabis
this is the computer suggestion and
pretty sure I wouldn't have played that
but if it is this is a yeah it is valid
it's not like i'm just getting
checkmated on the light squares maybe i
can take 27 is an idea preparing b6 yeah
that's not bad but this be 5 i'm totally
not sure about and here I'm I'm probably
in very good shape here yeah wyd win
safe this is a wind already + to work
according to stock fish I hope I played
the right moves but just pushing the
deep own is this it's probably winning
him yeah it was easy i just have to push
the deep on all the time and it it
promotes yeah i hope you enjoy this game
thanks for watching